former president put out a statement on
truth social today saying in part how can
doj possibly charge me who did nothing wrong
when no other presidents were charged he then
wrote about President Biden President Clinton
and invoked secretary Clinton's emails he ended
with the greatest Witch Hunt of all time do
you think he's worried about this I believe
the president's worried about otherwise he
wouldn't be commenting and he's rightfully
worried about it but I I think what you see
there and what you've heard we've heard this
in the town hall when Kaitlan asked about the
president said look I I have the right I can
declassify things just you know by saying
they're Declassified I think you're going
to hear that repeated over and over again I'm
not so sure that it means anything right to the
to the core dire ride Trump supporters I think
they're going to see this as more just you know
prosecution and persecution of their candidate
during you know he's he's the leader of the
Republican primary right now they're trying to
take him out and this is the best means they can